The following is a production of Frank Defratus and the Internet Museum of Holography.
The date is November 2098, 100 years into the future.
The scene is a memorabilia show dealing with antiques and collectibles from the late 20th century.
Hello, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk.
On this special broadcast, we're going to be taking a look at something I term antiquarian holographica, which is the collection of holographic memorabilia.
At our show, we see rare and first edition books, period maps and lithographs, and in a corner at the end of a long aisle is a booth dealing exclusively with holography.
Our imaginary booth has quite a selection, embossed holograms, including several limited edition pieces produced back in the late 1980s and 90s by a number of prominent artists.
A copy of the famous National Geographic cover with the American Eagle.
Signatures and autographs of the early movers and shakers in the field, posters and programs from early international shows, and first edition copies of many out-of-print books on holography.
And there's a real attention getter as well, an actual helium neon laser that the person in the booth tells you really works.
That is, if you can find a place that still uses electricity for power.
Our little scenario is not that far-fetched.
Many of the items related to holography that we pass over as insignificant, stuffed into our desk drawers and filing cabinets, will someday be looked upon as period pieces worthy of collection.
And since we can be fairly certain that we won't be around to attend our little imaginary convention in 2098, why not make the most of the time that we do have by attempting to put together an impressive collection of future holographic memorabilia?
Holotalk receives quite a few emails on a regular basis from its listeners, and many of those emails are asking for specific information relating to collecting.
One person wrote asking for information concerning a specific embossed hologram and how to acquire one for their collection.
Another from Europe spoke of the writer's pride in the collection of books and other printed materials, all related to the field of holography, but added that they were concerned that it was not complete.
Could it be, I wondered, that collecting holographic-related items was catching on around the globe?
The answer to that question appears to be in the affirmative.
Yes, there is collecting going on, and the real surprise is that it may prove to be the most active aspect of the field.
There appears to be a fever that goes hand in hand with the art of collecting.
Collectors can sometimes go through extreme trouble searching out materials, and nowhere are those materials more new and exciting than holography.
For a field celebrating its first few decades of existence, there is a multitude of collecting possibilities, including tracking down books and related articles that extend much further back in time than just a few decades.
There is a rich history and many centuries of art and science behind it, some of it extending back into the 16th and 17th centuries, all of it relating to holography today.
Searching out the articles, books, posters, and holograms from around the world to add to one's personal collection of holographic future memorabilia.
The mission of this broadcast is to provide a solid foundation for starting one's own archive on holography for future generations who will look back in time not only through the eyes of a collector, but a keeper of antiquarian holographica.
As with any new endeavor, it is important to have a plan, an ultimate destination for your collection.
Will you concentrate on books and publications?
Embossed holograms, posters and commemorative of exhibits, all of the above and more?
Remember, there is little, if any, background material available concerning collecting holography.
So much of the groundwork, legwork, and penwork, along with many hours of research, will have to be done by you, the collector.
The more you know, the more your collection will benefit, since much of your knowledge will show through in your aesthetic judgments and decisions.
Whatever your plan is for reaching your goal, it should never be executed in a haphazard way.
Decisions should be made intelligently and with great care as to what is worth having the honor of being part of your collection.
Remember, this isn't clutter or garage sale mentality we're talking about here, but a systematic recording of the history of holography.
Let's take a look at what a typical collection might contain.
We'll start with holograms.
Embossed holograms would be represented from around the world, both stock images and images that are unique.
There are also magazines, books, catalogs, brochures that have holograms on their cover or inside the issue.
These printed pieces and the embossed holograms would be carefully placed in black sleeves, numbered, identified, and stored carefully away from thumbing curiosity seekers.
Complete sets, such as the ET stickers from Hershey Reese's pieces, would round out the collection.
A unique ET set would have all nine images on one untouched sheet of foil.
These are much harder to come by, so would be valued more for a collection.
The new photopolymer holograms would also be considered a collectible.
The reflection holograms produced on film and sold throughout retail outlets across the US are also a consideration.
Publications.
Books.
Many books would be represented dealing with holography and its branches of lasers, light, and even philosophy.
One thing is certain.
Books are an expensive part of collecting.
Most books dealing with holography are not old enough or published in large enough numbers to be easily found on the used book rack.
Holography is a technical science, and technical manuals can run up quite a bill.
Fortunately, there are enough over-the-counter inexpensive soft covers to keep a collector busy for a long time.
Most bookstores will gladly special order titles for you, although some may put an additional finder's fee on the final cost.
But these charges are usually minimal.
First editions, especially those that are out of print, are a collector's dream and a field unto itself.
This is the creme de la creme of book collecting.
Whether you need first editions or simply a well-handled later edition is a matter of preference.
So looking to the future is a consideration that must be eventually confronted.
Letters and autographs.
Letters and autographs are collectibles too.
Letters are more of a personal collectible since many shouldn't be put on display or passed around.
A letter or document written entirely in the hand of its author is called a holograph.
A standalone signature is an autograph.
The letters I have on file are obviously due to the HoloTalk program and a newsletter that I published back in the eighties.
But if you were to write to a holographer, I'm sure they would be glad to write a short note back.
Since I don't know of any holographers who currently need to have protection from crowds of admirers, I'm sure your request would be flattering.
Remember, use discretion displaying the letter, note card, or autograph.
And don't pass over the beauty of the envelope.
Many foreign stamps, as well as US are truly works of art.
The quality and feel of the paper, the design and printing of the letterhead, the penmanship get a feel for all these things.
Many posters, announcements, and catalogs are still available through holography museums, galleries and manufacturers.
Many years ago, through neglect, I lost an original poster for the inaugural tour of the New York Museum of Hologies through the looking glass.
Don't make the same mistake.
Either put it on the wall or keep it in a cylinder.
Equipment catalogs are highly collectible.
Not only do they show photos of the error's existing technology, but many give technical drawings also.
Newport research catalogs have photos and blueprints for every piece of equipment.
As the field progresses, and mirrors, lenses, and filters are gradually replaced by fiber optic and holographic optical elements, and whatever will come after that, these catalogs will take on an air of nostalgia.
Just call a company and ask for a catalog.
Tell them your 300 plus employee company grossed 150 million last year, and you'll get it overnight express.
How about patents?
Well, the way things are going, the patents may become more famous than many holograms.
You can call the patent office in Washington, D.C.
and receive for a nominal fee all the patents applied for and granted in the field of holography.
Patents make a great addition to any collection.
Overall, collecting should be an enjoyable and rewarding experience.
You may have a collection started already and just never looked at it as so.
Go through your drawers and file cabinets, bookshelves, etc., and begin sorting things out.
You may be surprised at what's there.
Keep an eye open at all times for holograms and articles, books and magazines.
With the interest in holography continuing at an ever accelerating pace, and individuals who began their interest in holography several years ago now becoming more sophisticated in their appreciation of the medium, the time is right for a blossoming of interest in collecting works of holography.
However, while the most prominent artists in the field are beginning to find clientele willing to make substantial investments in their work, the majority of these works are priced beyond the means of the average enthusiast.
This leaves an area completely void, which is waiting to participate in collecting holograms.
It is believed that we may begin to fill that void by suggesting that a would-be collector begin by concentrating his or her efforts on building a collection of low cost and in many cases no cost, readily available embossed holograms.
Now, one may immediately remark that if embossed holograms are low cost and readily available, what would the collecting interest be?
To answer this, it must be pointed out that although many embossed holograms are low in cost, there are many that are difficult to find.
Also, since several holographic artists have created works that were limited edition embossed holograms, it is possible to own a work with only a modest investment by such artists as Harriett Casden Silver, John Kaufman, Dan Schweitzer, among others.
There are a few embossed holograms that are becoming harder and harder to find.
However, once located, an older, out-of-print, limited run embossed hologram is a treasure to own and view.
It is truly a collector's piece.
What does a beginning collector need to know?
Let's break it down.
It would be possible to have a combination of any single group classification with any single subgroup.
Let's clarify and define each group and subgroup.
Our groups are group one, two D graphic stickers.
These are the images that are line drawings or graphics and are essentially flat surface pictures.
Usually another 2D flat surface image will appear a short depth away from the front image.
The second image was usually a neutral field.
Many holograms of this type used a background of stars.
A good example for collection purposes would be the famous ET stickers found in packages of Reese's pieces.
The second group would be 3D images.
Now these embossed images are the same as a regular rainbow or white light transmission hologram that uses a three-dimensional object, be it real or abstract, as its image.
A good example would be one of the National Geographic covers.
Subgroups, now these groups are the subgroups of either group one, which is the 2D graphic sticker, or group two, 3D images.
An example would be any retail hologram sold only for its own purpose.
Subgroup B, packaging holograms.
Embossed holograms included in the packaging design of a consumer related product or its packaging materials, usually designed to attract or call attention to the product and enhance the product's visibility and or appeal.
Also used by companies to promote itself as future oriented or having a forward looking vision.
An example would be the hologram on a box for a camera.
Subgroup C artistic holograms.
These are usually limited edition pieces created by an established holographic artist with the masters made in the artist studio lab or rental facility and then mass produced by embossing, similar to a lithograph made from a painting.
An example would be Harriet Casden's Silver Magic Teeth, which had a run of 1,750 pieces and was offered in a sleeve that contained the artist's signature.
Subgroup D, experimental prototype holograms.
This type of embossed hologram is valued as a collectible for the simple reason that something about it makes it one of a kind.
An embossed hologram that was an artist's proof and still contained crop marks and cut lines would make that piece unique from the others that were to follow for retail sale.
While a person can certainly become overwhelmed by the sheer number of embossed holograms that have flooded the market since their inception.
With a certain amount of skill and work, it can become possible to build quite an impressive collection of embossed holographic images.
With regards to acceptance of embossed holograms within the holographic community, a purist attitude once prevailed in the collective minds of holographic artists.
Their initial concern about the viewing of their work, now removed from the hermetically sealed environment of the holography galleries and museums and now out on the street with the general public, was soon found to ring true.
At the site of the smeared gray image of the National Geographic cover.
Since an only added to rather than subtracted from holography's somewhat mystical appeal.
And you will have a hologram that will stand up visually to anything produced in limited quantities on glass plates.
Only a discerning eye, or someone with knowledge of the holographic process itself, would find discrepancies.
Embossed holograms are beautiful and fun to collect, and for a modest investment of your time and money, you can build an impressive collection of holograms for display.